[Music]
all right so again
uh the obviously this was a request so
uh and it was a request for a keyone 101
video but um I want people to be
thinkers okay uh I want you to be able
to
learn how to
think as it's being portrayed in the
training group and then you apply that
to your own art uh let's be honest you
you're already doing something I
wouldn't do okay so this is the next
best thing that I can think of I mean
what I would do and what I did is like
well who has what I want and uh then I
would just dedicate and devote myself to
that person uh I would move I would go
travel I would them to where I'm at uh I
wouldn't do what you guys do so the next
best thing is can you learn to think for
yourselves okay because my my position
is if you can learn to think for
yourselves then uh you might end up
exactly where I am okay it's just a very
long roundabout thing whereas if you
practice devotion it's the quickest
route that's that's why I did it that
way okay so learning how to think I was
really quite surprised by a lot of those
responses to be honest on the first
video because it was so coming from the
point of view like the iido this
fighting thing it's not this this is
fighting the fighting that you saw Rodin
that's fighting the fighting you see in
the in the Octagon that's fighting okay
uh this stuff is training for other
things okay but there's a lot of like no
no you know that wouldn't happen in a
real fight none of this stuff
would happen in a real fight Jesus
let go of it okay that that's where I'm
coming from uh and when you do let go of
it you can really discover what's
actually going on in here okay and there
is something valuable there um so here's
the next video to help you guys think
about this all right
so if we
look and he's
grabbing uh where we left off is it's
not him grabbing and striking that just
doesn't work okay it's me being grabbed
and me entering and him blocking the
strike that's what's going
on so if he grabs and is pulling me in
you'll see that his
elbow
goes from straight cuz he reached for
the grab and then his elbow bends this
we call this anchoring okay and the
stronger he wants to be the more the
elbow stays close to his rib cage and
the more down it goes that's going to
give him the most power the more his
elbow flares which people can pull like
that the less his elbows anchored the
less power he has okay so we won't train
for the the idiot we won't train for
that we'll train for the guy who really
understands
biomechanics
okay and then if you so all of you who
said that the guy that you enter
okay or that you were taught that you
enter I made in the follow-up post that
it's not that I'm entering on a guy
who's fist is
straight and whose elbow is straight
sorry it's a guy I'm in train on the
pull which means I'm in train on the
anchoring of the
elbow which means if he's here I don't
try to enter because I can't
enter because there's no way I can enter
on him so hence in that second series of
posts I
made entering without the elbow of
pulling is as wrong as turning when he's
penetrating forward they're both a
violation of yan yangong Theory okay
so I'm not initiating anything because
there's no initiation on that there's no
way I can do that I am responding to the
pulling he pulls that's what I'm
doing
now what usually
happens let's say again my Desi don't we
don't work with this crap so what
usually happens is the UK is going to
choreograph away all violations of Yong
Theory okay uh so when he come when he
enters on the strike I know don't worry
and he enters on the
strike the
UK goes ahead and go ahead and let that
that happened you see that's what
happens every time so it looks like he's
there and I go there that's that's what
it looks like but you see I did I did
that I did this Bend in my arm whereas
the guy is trying to inj on me what
you you see I'm not going that's not
going to happen that's a violation of
Yin okay so I'm going to let them play
with that uh but that's first point in
this second video
all right so as that's just dumb but
people just do it
okay
um now let's go well clearly it is that
he has to pull me in and clearly his
elbow has to Anchor to pull me in okay
if that's true and he goes to do it and
I he he pulls me down and you can see
that he blocks in his attack he blocks
my arm that was supposedly hitting him
in the face just from the anchored elbow
okay so the way they do it in the
fedorite world is he come you come
underneath but if he was pulling you he
blocks the arm in the pull I can't get
my arm up okay we'll do it from the
other side in chasing you can see both
angles just in the pull no he's blocking
in the pole itself one more
time okay and we'll try that one so they
can feel this all right we'll watch my
fists
now as I plot this in space but it's it
should be obvious it's just appar
obviously it wasn't obvious okay and
then that's how you get people entering
in coming underneath like that just
doesn't work okay but if you pay
attention mention why doesn't it work
okay to Anchor my
elbow my fist has to descend so if you
plot it in the vertical plane my fist is
coming
down there's no way I can leave it at
this
level and anchor my elbow to leave the
fist at that level my elbow cannot
anchor it's going
outward the second my elbow anchors the
fist has to come
down when the fist comes down he brings
his arm up that's a young young Clash
okay that he will lose because I have
elbow power and he's trying to use his
wrist power on that you'll lose that
every time okay that's why it doesn't
work that's a Yong Yong Clash why is it
not noticed because the U is
choreographing The Clash away okay so
what do we have to do
instead I can't come underneath the arm
so I go over the arm he's pulling I come
here
okay try that one try it all right so a
kind of insert here because his his
elbow is anchoring the fist goes down as
uh you can't Lurch step so Lurch step to
me is when you take your line of gravity
and you're moving it between your
feet so if he's not there take no you're
there but not pulling AER step looks
like
this and a lot of people do that because
they want the mer the gravitational
marriage on the
Strip but if I do
that when he goes he does this anchoring
elbow go and I try to do that you get
checked out okay you have to work the
energy so the fist go is going down
right away and that's where you have to
drop
so side note cuz we had a lot of
problems working that everyone was lurge
stepping okay if you're stepping
correctly he goes your energy on the
hand is going
up
not down on a ler step okay and then
secondarily once you touch something I
touch up there I'm touching here okay so
he he goes I drop in I try to touch his
Center I'm
not just popping him in the head okay
but we're going to do that part
again all right so to that that's where
he defends his face he goes defends his
face when I touch that I'm still in his
Center so I'm not here go and I'm
hitting here let
touch in his Center
okay let try that all right so that that
would be my take on the problems as they
were set up in the first video
okay and then prayer request is how to
do how to get to Niko okay so a couple
things that we have always said the
fight must spiral rotate okay and so the
spiral rotation is I got to get off of
this 180
okay um and he has to end up at a
minimum over here at the
4:00 preferably the 3:00 okay we got to
start spiral
rotating so what ends up happening as I
would diagnose reverse engineer this
technique is is I came in okay but he's
really strong so that I will not get
that other technique
okay we're going to go slow so I can
talk okay so he's pulling in I'm trying
the other technique I feel the strength
I let it PA and then I keep him moving
in the
circle so again nice and slow boom he's
strong enough let it pass here's the
other hand the other hand passes takes
them into that
curvature do the other
[Music]
side notice how as he goes in the other
hand is here covering whatever this
might do so I don't want it as I come up
and he just punches me in the face okay
the other hand is there that's why the
other hand as it yields the other hand
picks it up and this one now is on the
on this guard here okay so as we're here
it comes around here
okay let's try so again I'm learning how
to think all that I have done at this
point was use Yong theory that is all
I've done okay and this what is the
actual biome mechanical
soundness that would get me in this
situation okay so for example he has to
be pulling otherwise I wouldn't be
entering and then martially go ahead
double check it yeah if he's not pulling
me I couldn't anyways
okay uh another thing you can use to
validate your thinking because the art
is concentric if you get onto the right
track it is a track that you've already
been on multiple times okay so if you
pay attention if he did for example
Yoki and we came
here you're going to see that that is
what's happening here okay so we'll go
slow so I can talk we all know why this
first part is happening w't feel that
and right here is the strip we come back
all the time and
you
okay going
in it's right there all I'm doing is not
taking the strike to emphasize the arm
check but it's there if you wanted it
okay
okay to show you how the where the Yoko
manucci is we pull him in feel the
pressure it's right there
boom one more
[Music]
time okay so we used yinong Theory to
get us into the ballpark we confirmed
martially what is actually people do
what's actually going to happen happen
and then now we use a concentric uh
manifestation yep seen that before it's
true cuz this is a concentric epist
epistemology at work here uh and now uh
what we have and we also rotate the
fight you always have to rotate the
fight it's part of the Arts principle so
we rotated the fight you can see that UK
going off the
180 and doing those what is it 245
I don't know what is it andw to 3/4 is
270 270 we hit the 270 which we always
have to hit Okay so we're we're in the
ballpark everything's consistent and
valid um now we want to hit the Niko
okay and the Niko like all locks on the
extremities require that the arm get
isolated and what that means is that it
requires that his elbow is not near his
torso okay otherwise you can't do this
kind of stuff um so that is why what I
mean by that is he pulls in and I'm here
you can't you're not going to get any F
here okay you have to get separation
between the elbow and the Torso now the
arm is isolated now the elbow's
vulnerable and now the wrist is
vulnerable otherwise it's not okay so if
you pay attention in everything that
we've done up till now the arm is
getting longer is what I'm doing okay
because the centrifugal energy is
extending him out from me this way okay
does that make sense okay so now I got
to figure
out
how to get to the N over here all right
so in in light of everything that I've
done so probably back to Y
Theory so here goes I'm coming around
right and that is going to be pulling
against the centrifugal energy that I
used
okay so usually what tends to happen is
I got to figure out how to
move where that's not going to be okay
where that pull is not going to be so
let me
expl if C tripical
energy is pulling them
out it's like any other force and the
non-c contesting line is at the 90 to
it okay and that's what I ended up using
so he's coming around if I go this way
you'll feel the pull I got to hit the
90 to the centrifugal force line
so be and then there's nothing then you
have okay 's try it on the other
side I did all this for a reason stated
I extend the arm I take to
90 okay let's just get there and see
what happens try it all right I'm going
to show it again CU it's a little weird
here okay so go really slow so I can
talk he's going in boom I feel her
streng so I yield to the strength so you
got to give some
energy okay she didn't let go that's the
first thing to know if she let go she'd
go she let go she'd come around and
you'd have sh Naga and all that kind of
stuff so this is a
technique that's kind of answering the
what if what if they didn't let go okay
if they didn't let go this interical
force would isolate the arm by having
the body and the elbow elbows separate
from each other okay so
one and there it
is there it is okay and now I can't go
here so this pull line I go
here okay and that's where I
find the
Nik
here do it again
and and
boom boom here find it
here if you want
to change the foot you could but it's
still at that point Bo here
I had no project here did you see so
you're going
to uh
pull then you're pushing there with your
body enough that I would do that okay
yes and if you paid attention your arm
extended last time I had to push project
you on there okay so we can go slow and
you can feel those
forces a one we push in off there you go
there's the arm extension
okay so again
one one here I
go go
slower slower so you don't go so
fast like there's still energy there it
is here I go
One More
Time Boom
through boom here that time you did not
get all right try okay and so now I have
my non-c contestation theory that you
always use it's 90 to the inertial
pathway and we're doing that again I
have my arm isolation uh principles that
you always have to use uh and now you
can also see oh I have another
concentricity so if we're doing just
straight
kadori um eel is the same thing his arm
was here I move out to the side with
that same foot workk and then you attack
the wrist there okay uh all in that
technique the arm is already isolated
when you when you did that technique
okay so if you pay attention that's all
that's happening here but the energy is
right there that I am using okay but the
footwork is the same there's something
that's different
though and that is that because of the
energy that's happening you this doesn't
work so good so if you pay attention I
take a two on one and I turn I turn I
turn that okay so watch this is very
common in in fighting like we're here
like that you you never go like that
because he's going to open up the E
right there okay so someone's grabbing
you you're always here like this here on
top and you're turning that thing around
okay so very similarly done here so pay
attention on
this boom to turn it into place okay
once it's in place then you take and
you're in just standard me
okay let's try
this came up uh again when I do my Keon
waza if you pay attention I use my body
and what I mean by that is the rotation
of my body of the pattern that my body
is taking in space to do much of the
wrist turning um in for something like
Niko or sonio or something like that
okay uh so because the reason for this
is grab okay and don't let me turn your
wrist I'll break it if you let
me turn it
there's no way just it's impossible you
cannot do that okay so what we're doing
here is I have a two onone now you see
and I get maybe
there that's about where it stops do you
see but now here's where my body
turns and you pay attention the Nel's on
get to turn it's right
there
okay so don't expect
as you're doing this technique you're
grabbing here and he's got this
centrifical energy you see don't
expect this to
get this all the way to
there you're just here you get that turn
and then you turn this right there okay
and now you have
it don't get over anxious on that okay
what'll happen is in the fight you took
too long you stayed in place the SP
rotation is coming to a stop and the guy
counters you you're never strong enough
okay what we're doing instead I get
enough angle I move to keep the spiral
rotation going and then I end up having
the lock if I don't have the lock I'm
still in the zone of sanctuary do you
see and the guy let go probably and I'm
going
he let go of me which was the problem
okay you go on to something else okay